you know the story told about you know
when they come home your dad comes up
and says Andrew I'll see you in a couple
weeks and he's out right in the context
of what happens when there's a conflict
and we all react in three different ways
fight flight freeze yeah in that context
your daddy's flight yeah he runs
obviously I don't want to deal with it
I'm out of here I'm gonna do my own
thing okay
in America a lot of that is happening
right now where it's a singly single
parent household kids are being raised
without a mom and dad being there and
it's just one mom you know a mom trying
to do both and these boys you know my
mom couldn't tell me what to do from a
very once my parents got a divorce yeah
I'm a single mother raising me I've seen
my dad every other week so it's not like
he has direct influence to discipline me
until I went into the military yeah
how much of that like if you were to go
back and think about what if your dad
didn't take the flight approach what if
your dad took the fight approach what if
your parents were together wouldn't have
made a difference in you and how do you
view you know the idea of fathers being
there with Mom and Dad together family
nuclear family nucleus because a lot of
times you know
the marriage no longer has you know the
the
what it once had you know like kids are
better off being raised with a mom and
dad how do you process that yourself
because you became successful not being
in that environment correct so do you
see this as well it depends there's
exceptions to the rule how do you
process it I think it's a fantastic
environment and I think in an idealistic
world that's the way it would be I think
the reason it's not happening today is
that I don't think many men actually
benefit from marriages or relationships
anymore and people are always going to
have to require some degree of incentive
I think that we've set up the world now
in a way where men are seen as worker
droids they're expected to go work all
day come home uh clean up as well share
the cleaning with the woman not have any
not no meal prepared for them not have
any authority over the household and
just and just be a worker Droid and be
sad and I don't think that many people
understand that men are intrinsically
wired to desire respect amongst our
peers and in our environments this is
why CEOs work so hard because they get
respect in their company this is is why
we all want so much money in Fast Cars
and status and influence because we're
respected men desire respect like we
desire oxygen and if a man's coming home
to a household where he doesn't feel any
respect he's not going to want to be
there for very long and I think the way
you fix this is you need to understand
that
many men don't have an incentive to be
in the house anymore I think that it's
actually would be quite easy for a woman
in fact there's a couple women who even
say this on YouTube I can't remember
their names but it'd be quite easy for a
woman to make a man really happy with
super basic things just go up to your
husband and say hey
you know more about this what do you
think about this
that would make most men's World and
there's so many sexless marriages out
there with men who work their ass off
and they come home to a sexist marriage
and kids who don't [ __ ] even like
them
if you were to just even ask him his
question about some asinine [ __ ] a
lawnmower purchase
he would feel so happy to feel like the
man of the house that's what men need
they need to feel like all this work I'm
putting in all this [ __ ] I'm going
through I'm respected for it as soon as
a man feels like he has no respect
that's the absolute end of a man's
interest or a man's tolerance of a
situation I think that's the reason it's
happening I think I know a lot of men
who completely love their wives they
love them with all their heart they die
for her but he's just not respected in
his house he doesn't get to be the man
of the house is it on him or is it on
her like does he need to go earn it or
is it on her to provide it it's a
combination of both I think it's
certainly on him to earn it but also the
Matrix programming is counter to him the
Matrix programming is trying to tell him
that he shouldn't be allowed to be the
man of the house that he shouldn't be
allowed to have any kind of authority in
any regard you shouldn't be allowed to
be able to say what happens The Matrix
programming saying the absolute opposite
all the time and if that's getting into
your woman and you don't have that much
influence and that's getting to all your
children you don't have that much
influence now you're coming home to a
household where everyone just thinks
you're the dude who should just [ __ ]
work you're just a worker Droid you're
the slave you're the robot and your
feelings don't matter and you're
Authority doesn't matter get [ __ ] and
this is this is very conscious if you
watch any Netflix show the mother is the
smart one and the man is the bumbling
idiot turn on a show I dare you turn on
a family show the mother is the one hey
hey calm down I'm smart and the man's
look who beer
watch any of these shows
Married with Children they're reducing
they're reducing demands and just
bubbling it in and it's very hard I
think for a lot of men to accept being a
position of constant disrespect I'll
tell you this now if I had to choose a
long lasting marriage with a woman who
loved me or a woman who truly respected
me I might choose respect
over love even though they're the same
thing for a woman because she loves you
she respects you by default but if I had
to choose I'd choose respect I've been
through too much and worked too hard and
go through too much in day-to-day life
to come home to my house and be having
battles over asinine [ __ ] I take
care of you and I love you with all of
my heart I would die for you if someone
broke into this house I would Engage The
Invader and die I'd please just cook
dinner please like what you want from me
what more can I do for you like and once
they feel disrespected there's another
thing about the world that a lot of
people don't understand it's disrespect
that will drive a man to the most
heinous of crimes it's disrespect that
starts the school shooter [ __ ] it's
disrespect that makes men go to jail for
life sentences it's disrespect when you
truly disrespect a man in a public and
permanent way that's when they switch
that's why I'm so respectful in public
you don't know who the [ __ ] you're
talking to he might go on his last
[ __ ] straw and you're just
disrespecting hey you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway you're skinny [ __ ] [ __ ]
you you don't know that might be the
last time you heard it I've had enough
you don't know disrespect is dangerous
right and in a household where you're
constantly disrespecting a man he's
going to end up depressed and sad for
even accepting it men just want to feel
respected it's not that hard to do if a
woman if you choose to anyone watching
this if you truly love your man it would
be so easy easy for you to just make him
feel respected it doesn't even take
actions you can do it with basic words
ask his opinion on something big him up
once in a while and because we're
supposed to be Superman and we purport
ourselves as Superman and we're stoic
but we talked earlier about how we still
feel everything so when you're a strong
man especially they're like ah he's fine
he's fine he's fine he's fine be nice to
the dude you'd be surprised how far you
get but this is why I think most men
walk out marriages because they're like
you know what I'm not getting any
respect here I get more respect from
this [ __ ] stripper 18 year old hoe
for throwing money at her that I do
given money to my own wife where am I
being respected well at least she's
smiling at me she ain't smiling at me in
years if you enjoyed this video and you
want to watch the entire podcast click
over here and if you want to be
connected with experts influencers such
as Kiyosaki Tate Connolly parliamentary
myself and others download the app
connect where you get a chance to
connect with these folks by the minute
you get to buy the minute or have face
times with them 15 minutes asking any
questions you may want to have download
the app minute and start connecting with
influencers and experts today
foreign
[Music]